welcome to simply learns python tutorial
my name is Richard Kirchner with the
simply learned team that's WW simply
learn comm get certified get ahead today
we're gonna cover Python one of today's
highly utilized programming languages
for its many diverse uses I'll be
working in hi charm PyCharm is put out
by JetBrains sww JetBrains comm slash
pycharm slash where you can download it
the benefits of using PyCharm
is it creates an in virtual environment
so you can change what version of python
you're using you can make all kinds of
alterations in there for this tutorial
any Python IDE will work but will be in
the PyCharm setup it is a really good
setup to use on there and again you can
download it here from the jetbrains
website so in the pycharm environment
and if you're not using this you'll need
to follow whatever ide setup you have
for doing a new project we've created a
new project we're gonna create a new
scratch file this scratch file we call
whatever it is we want it's gonna be a
Python file since we're working in
Python they call it scratch 3 Python we
can also rename this you can see I have
a number of other scratch files delete
them remove them whatever you need to do
so we're going to be working on our
Python in this IDE and again whatever
IDE you use will work just fine for this
Python tutorial and we're gonna start
with variables in Python the most
fundamental building block you need
variables are entities of program that
hold a value x equals 100 the box is
holding a variable would be the name
given to the box and if you study basic
algebra x equals 3 x equals 100 it goes
a little bit beyond just equaling
numbers because we can also do words but
we're gonna look at just variables and
let's go ahead and pull that up in our
user interface and see what that
programming looks like in the script
language so in python we can do
something like print this is a simple
print statement so whatever we put in
here is printed back out so we're gonna
put in here meat Jane and let's also
have it print Jane works as a software
engineer and then that's also
one more print line just seen see we're
looking at print and then we have Eli's
is Jane's manager and in here you can
run it a number of ways we'll go
underneath run and here's our alt shift
f10 also does this and it asks me what
do I want to run I want to run the
scratch three cuz I have little scratch
files in there and we'll click on there
and it'll run it if you're on like a
different ID you might pop up with the
black box that prints it out and you can
see here it says meet Jane Jane works as
a software engineer
Elise is Jane's a manager I always take
that space out so it just looks nicer as
we have that it's kind of nice if you
just want to print something out and
there certainly is a lot of times when
you want to print the title of something
you might have your HTML code on the
server and you print it out and that's
what people actually see if they go to
the Python and it accesses that Python
code will print out the HTML and it'll
just be text printing it out now
this is all great let's go ahead and put
a comment in here just so we can track
what's going on a comment uses the hash
tag so this just tells that this isn't
code this is just a comment for now as
well we're programming and this over a
little bit C of better space on here
instead of typing Jane every time we can
also store it as a variable so let's go
ahead and store that and we'll call it
name equals Jane so now we have the
variable name and now we can do
something like this we can go print
there's our brackets we want meat and
I'm just gonna do a simple comma
everything that's separated between
commas they'll print out in a row so we
have meat and then we'll just do the
name and if I run this you'll see me
Jane Jane works as a software engineer
Elisa's Jane's manager and then just
says meet Jane because we've replaced
the name with Jane and we'll take this
off the top I'm just going to delete
that out of there so we can move on to
this next setup with variables and we
can also go print this is kind of a cool
system because I can now do string we
can hold a space for a string it works
as a software engineer and then if
you're going to put a placeholder in
there it has to know what the
placeholder stands for and this is one
of the formatting options when you print
something out so do something simple
like this we have a placeholder for a
string works as a software engineer
except the place holes are supposed to
be inside the brackets and when we hit
run you'll see meet Jane and then you
also prints Jane works as a software
engineer
right down here in the output the
terminal output from the run so instead
of having to type Jane over and over
again we can now put a placeholder in
there and the same thing with the last
set up print
lease is and there's our placeholder the
percentage sign and the S and then we
have name after word let's go ahead and
run that and you can see here that we've
now printed out the the first one meet
Jane and notice that this puts more a
little bit more it has one space in here
but you don't really control the spacing
on here so when we do a formatting and
we insert it as part of the format you
can see right here we put the name it
now has a nice format like I couldn't do
this with a comma but I can certainly do
this down here with the apostrophe s for
Elise's Jane's manager and then we can
also instead of having Jane up here
maybe Jane got fired and Mae got hired
well let's just say there's a second
employee named Mae so now we have the
name Mae in here and I can run this and
you'll say it now prints meet Mae Mae
works as a software engineer
Elisa's Mae's manager so we've just
swapped me in for Jane and then one
other important feature of Python
variables is we could have named two
also equal to may keep the same name on
there let's go ahead and print we'll do
ID of name and then I also want to print
the ID of name too and what the ID does
is the ID goes in there and says hey
where is this name coming from let's go
ahead and run that and you'll see it
actually gives us a memory address and
so one of the things you find out about
Python is to help save memory you just
swap this out of here in Python
variables with the same value hold the
same memory space so we have name equals
to may name to Eagles may we print the
idea of name and name to and you'll see
that they occupy the same memory space
now if we happen to swap one of these
out we'll do Jane again we run it they
now have two different memory spaces so
even though I make changes in here this
is one of the ways that python is really
good about saving memory in the computer
and the last thing we want to know here
which leads us into the next piece of
programming is that this is a string up
here name equals Jane so we're talking
about different data we really have to
also talk about different data types and
very specifically we're going to look at
numerical data so we
about numeric data talking numbers the
various types of numeric data are
integer float and complex there are an
advanced programming additional
numerical data types which have to do
how it stores the data but these three
are the ones you need to know about to
get started in your scripting language
and the most commonly used and so an
integers is simply that it's at number
equals five and then if I print and you
can always find out what type of
variable you have if you do a type on it
so we're gonna print type number and so
if I run this that comes out and it says
class integer down here so this is an
integer number and you can also do
negative on these so if I run minus five
it's still a class integer whether it's
plus or minus and the most the second
most commonly used number is your float
and it's just like it sounds we have
this to a number equals five point six
and if you notice I used the same
variable name num on there so I can
actually take this and I can just copy
this and at some point we'll talk about
ways of not having to recopy your code
so you can create definitions but let's
go take a look at this we have our float
or number now equals five point six and
if we print the number type will see
that it is first an integer and then a
float value let's do this just a number
just remember we're looking at number
and then finally complex so if we have a
complex number well go ahead I'm gonna
keep number in there usually you don't
leave it as number because then it
confuses the code later on but just for
this particular piece of code we're
gonna keep it number and I'm gonna do
five plus six j and let's go ahead and
print that out so we can see what these
look like and here's our number comma
type number and let's run this and let's
see we got here we have a five which is
an integer five point six which is a
float so it has a decimal place there
that's what the float stands for so your
five point six five point seven five
point eight and then we have five plus
six j is a complex number and if you
remember from math complex number is
based off of I squared equals minus one
or the square root of minus one is that
imaginary number now I'll be honest with
you I don't use imaginary numbers much
unless something comes up where I take a
square root of a minus one and then I
end up with the return of a complex
number so it's important to know it's
there and know what it is when it comes
up and with anything you do have to be
pay attention when you do conversions so
we can convert these things back and
forth and this could put a little note
here versions and let's start by oh this
just dude here's our print and we'll go
ahead and do our number type back to
what we were doing before so we know
what the type it is and type number so
it's just from before on there and let's
say we want to convert it from a regular
number to a float and we can simply do
something that looks like this and let's
go ahead in place there's our number but
I want to convert it so I'm going to
convert it to float and then if we do
that over here too and I go float that
in brackets so we're gonna print this
out and if I run this we now have five
is a class integer five point zero is a
float so I've converted it to a float
here and we can also convert this to a
complex just like we did here with float
I can simply put in complex and we'll do
that over here also complex number and
if I run this we now have 5 + o J so
this is a complex number there's no
actual negative imaginary numbers as
part of it so you're going to get just a
zero in the J part so this is one way to
convert it and you convert it this way
we'd also convert it back so you can
convert to in between any of these and
let's take our number let's make it
worth five point six so if you remember
correctly this is now a float and if we
want to take that float value print
integer of our number and of course type
integer of our number and if we run this
we started off here with five point six
so by default it automatically makes it
a float value and here we have it we
converted a float to a float so it's not
gonna really do anything and then we
convert it to an integer look what
happens as an integer as an integer it
just truncates the six right off so
you've got to be very careful when
you're going the wrong direction on this
if you're going from float to integer
you're gonna lose a decimal value if
you're going for a miniature to flow
which is very common thing to do
especially with data science you don't
lose anything you just gain the decimal
place so if I when we did it earlier we
had five became 5.0 and then you can see
where it becomes a complex number and we
can do that just about any direction you
want with the
version pythons really nice that it lets
you do that but you do have to be
careful that you don't lose information
that you need so we've looked at
variables we've looked at numerical
variables and how they differ the next
question is what happens if you have a
lot of data you really can't just number
one number two number three that's
really not gonna work in programming so
three of our basic lists is lists in
Python a list is a collection of data
and it can hold values of multiple data
types so you can see here we've set a
value of variable X and we'll set it
equal to 189 a hey zero B and it can
store that in there there's also the
tuple so we have list tuple and set the
tuple almost has the same format as the
list but instead we put the curved
brackets around it and what this means
is a tuple is an immutable collection of
heterogeneous data big mouthful there
what it means is once I set the tuple I
can't go in there and change one piece
of it as far as the tuple is concerned
that's one variable where a list is a
list of sub variables 189 a a 0 B a to
boil you can't change anything in here
now you can access it the same way you
do a list but you can't make any changes
on this tuple other than completely
overwriting it and then finally there's
a set we put brackets around it now
there's some other more complex data
sets to go with this to go above or
data-type collections of data but these
are the three basics and a set is an
unordered collection of unique
heterogeneous data so it's unique so if
you put in 1 5 3 hey 6 Python and I try
to add 6 in here it will only store one
value of 6
says these are all unique in here so
let's jump into our IDE and let's create
a list remember use of square brackets
that's how we denote that this is going
to be a list let's just throw some
numbers in there 4 5 7 5 so now I have a
list and we can do a simple thing like
print the list and if we run this we'll
see it come out down here as 1 4 5 2 7 5
and one of the cool things about lists
is that these are indexes and this is
kind of important to understand what the
index means so we'll go ahead and print
lists and it always starts with
so if I run this and I print zero is
going to print the one because that's in
the zero place and if we print here's
our list we print a 1 on there and we
run that we have four cuz that's in the
one place so 0 1 2 3 4 5 so there's 0
through 5 and this is interesting
because if we print let me go back up
here to the top I'm just gonna print Lin
which stands for length of list it's
just going to return the length of the
list and I'm gonna run this and you'll
see it says there's six things in there
but it starts at zero so we reference
them as 0 through 5 now if you're new to
this that can be confusing especially
when you're jumping back and forth in
your code so I always remember this is
point 0 through 5 it's not 1 through 6
is zero through five but there are six
entities in the list that's the length
of the list and we showed you here we
can access your zero index your one
index you can also access it from the
right-hand side by simply adding a
negative number in there so if I add a
negative one and I run this helps them
actually put the list in front of it
there we go run you'll see that points
to the last one in the list so negative
1 is the 5 this again that little
confusing you can't do a negative 0 so
negative 1 going backwards it starts at
1 and if I change the negative 1 say 2 2
you'll see it'll go to the 7 prints the
7 out there so we can do some very basic
indexing and look at any one of these
entities in the list and then get the
length of the list so we know how long
our list is now really common is not
just to want one entity instead of
wanting just one entity in here let me
just get rid of some of the notes here
so that we can see what this looks like
I might want to access the first 4
values so I can do print list 0 4 and
your first thought might be that we
count this 0 1 2 3 4 which would be 5
entities but we don't count the 4 so
this is 0 to 3 so whenever you see this
access from left to right positive side
it's going to give us the first 4
element but it starts with 0 0 1 2 3
which is our 1 4 5 2 and since we're
starting from the beginning you can
always just leave the 0 out and we can
do something like this it gives us the
same answer whether you put the 0 in or
leave the 0 out it automatically suit
you're starting from the beginning of
the list likewise we can start from
position two and go forward and if you
notice here we get five two seven five
position two
if you look at this we have zero one two
two points to the five position so if
you're going from left to right you just
say hey I want position two and you get
everything to the end and we could also
put a second number in here like four
that's just two three you get two values
remember it doesn't include the four on
here it does include the two just like
you can do indexes with negative numbers
I can now do minus four so this means
that I'm starting with zero I can leave
it out so the Python way is to leave it
out you don't need all that extra script
and it goes up to a negative four or
where's negative four
here's one two three four so this should
go up to this location but not include
it and sure enough we get 1 4 so it goes
up to negative 4 remember when you're
reading it this way from left to right
you don't include the minus 4 you
include the first one but not the second
one and you can also put the negative
over on the other side and go minus 4
and if we run this one now we get 5 2 7
5 so we have 1 2 3 4 and remember it's
on the left-hand side so we include it
so we have five 275 coming out in the
bottom and the last really fun trick you
can do you just take the minus 4 out is
I'm going to add a second colon here and
a 2 and I'm gonna run this and it should
print out every other one so goes one it
skips one so it counts it one two one
two and we get the one five and seven
coming out and you can see that down
here and you can add in any of your
other numbers in here so we could start
at 1 instead of at zero and now you get
4 to 5 so again we're skipping every
other one but now we're starting with
the digit in the index number one place
last thing to note is that these are all
integers if I put a one point zero in
and I run it it's going to give me an
error it says I can't slice a float
value even though it knows what one is
it needs to be an integer and that's
important to know if you're slicing your
data into thirds I don't know how many
times I forget to do that change it
convert it back to an integer and it'll
say I can't slice three point six six
six six
whatever it is Schwimmer to convert that
into integers so another thing to
remember about lists they can be mixed
so I can come in here and instead of it
being all in this case we had all
integers I could easily put Python in
here and instead of 7 will do 7 point 4
comma 5 and if I print this out let me
just take that out of here by the way is
this this functionality of the index
works identical no matter what's in your
list but we come in here and you'll see
I have one for python 27.45 and lists
are mutable so just like I did just like
I referenced the index I can say list of
let's do one which is gonna be the for
place equals let's do hello and if I
print my list now you'll see down below
where it comes out goes from one for
Python 27.45 to one hello python 27.45
and because these are mutable with the
lists we can also do something like list
dot append and we can append simply
learn and now if I print my list out and
I run this you'll see that I've added
simply learned to the end of the list
and if I do a length of the list it's
now gone from 6 to 7 oh let's just do
that real quick print length of list so
now it's 7 so we've added one more unit
to the list
they're very mutable very flexible use
of setting up lists and then we can also
take this list let's let's do a new one
we'll call it nested we can create
nested lists what that means is that
here's my brackets to define that it's a
list and I can fill this with whatever
objects I can think of these can be
anything but we'll stick to numbers I'll
do one two and then I'm gonna also
create a nested list and we'll create 2
comma 3 comma 4 so now I have a list
within a list so now we have a nested
list and if we print this this is print
our nested list out you'll see down
below it prints it out just like I typed
it 1 2 comma 2 3 4 s and nested inside
the nested list and then another option
to append is we can also do nested
extent and we could go in here and let's
create my nested loop so I'm adding a
nested loop to a nested loop this is
kind of interesting because you'll see
here I have
sub-lists attached to the list and I'm
going to take the nested extend them to
extend this on here and if I run this if
I take this and run this and make sure
I'd print the nested again you can see
how it's been transformed and they got
one two two three four and that's added
the seven eight nine on there now I was
just adding one nested list on here I'd
probably just a pen brackets around
seven eight nine but if you were adding
multiple nested lists on here you might
do something you want to use the extend
on here so we have one two sub list two
three four sub list seven eight nine and
sub list five six seven so I've added
two different new nested lists on to
this so we've looked at lists we've
covered indexing of lists we've covered
appending or extending and sub lists
let's go ahead and talk about tuples and
tuples are really important I am amazed
when I first heard about him I was like
why why have a list and why have a tuple
so the tuple is your curved brackets
around in this case we're gonna do one
two three and the most important thing
to know about the tuple is I can't
change it I can't go in there and change
the one to a zero now I can change tuple
and have it equal something else but I
can't change the pieces of the tuple and
that's what's so important about the
tuple on this and you'll see when I
print it it also prints it with the
curved brackets so that lets me know
that this is immutable I cannot change
the two Bowl now we can access the tuple
just like you did the list I can print
tuple position one and if I run that
it's gonna print two because remember we
start with zero one I can do just the
same way we did the indexing I can do up
to one which should print just the one
cuz zero and it doesn't include the one
there's our tuple comes out with one
comma so a little different output
you'll see this kind of notation when
you're accessing slices of a tuple and
you know all the different functionality
for indexing is the same we can even do
it in Reverse
we didn't show you that on the list but
this works just as well on the list
instead of the two for skipping we can
do a minus one and that just goes in
Reverse so now I have a tuple of three
two one so I talked about it not being
able to be changed if we take and just
get rid of the print for a second and
let's print let's do this tuple of one
is now going to equal
seven if I run this it's gonna throw an
error because we cannot change the
pieces of the tuple I can reassign
something else to TPL a variable but I
can't change it it's immutable and one
of the very common uses of a tuple is to
use it as a key for something else now
we're not gonna cover keys and codes in
this tutorial but imagine if you have an
address to a house and the house is 1 2
3 main street and someone can just
change that address then your house just
kind of jumps all over the place so you
want that address to be unchangeable
immutable and this is like a key code so
it's probably a key to some data so it's
a reference usually at some point or
some kind of data that can doesn't needs
to be set and unchanged when you set up
for a tuple and we can do there's some
other cool things we can do with a to
bolt now this is take this one we can do
something you can do this what they call
packing and unpacking tuples so just
like we assign the tuple 1 2 3 I can
also do tuple equals we'll do 5 6 8 just
because and if I print tuple and we run
that it's still going to create a tuple
out of it and so we're saying hey this
tuple is equal to these three values
whatever they are and now this variable
is equal to these three values and I
mentally converts it into a tuple if you
do it that way and we can unpack our
tuple I can do a comma B comma C equals
2 bolt and if we print a comma B comma C
run that you'll see we get our 5 6 8
right back so we can unpack it and pack
it you see this a lot when you're doing
definitions in programming where you're
packing and unpacking the data you'll
get to the point when you're doing
scripting you don't even notice or think
about it till you're like oh yeah that
is a tuple remind you on that one but it
does come up a lot and then another
strange thing I can do is I can do a
star list now in this list is a variable
and a is also our letter A just from
right above and I'm gonna set that equal
to a tuple and let's print that out
let's print a comma list and if I run
this you'll see that I get 5 which is
our a and then it creates a list out of
the remainder so once I pulled a out of
the first part I now have lists in there
and I could
a comment become a sequels tubule so
this is straight from up above where we
have ABC equals tuple a comma star list
just splits them up into two parts the
first part it refers to is just the
value and the second part it puts into a
list square brackets so you can see how
that's set up in there and how you can
pull that information and manipulate it
and then well finally we'll look at set
and you can create a set s equals and
usually you denote it with the squiggly
brackets and one two three three four
five and if you look at this if you
remember the set should not repeat any
values so if I print set and I run this
I now get one three four five and I'll
get rid of all my duplicates threes so I
can only have unique values in a set and
if we're looking at this this is also a
subgroup of a tuple so that means that
if I do s of one and I try to change one
of the members in there equals one so
I'm trying to change position one which
is a three to a one and I run that
that's gonna give me an error I can't
change it I can tap into it so it's just
like a tuple I can't change these values
in the set what I can do is I can take a
list and let's just let's just change
this will go list equals we'll change
these to square brackets so now I have
my standard list I will do a list down
here print our list and then I'm going
to print and we'll use the keyword set
and we're going to change this from a
list to a set and then I'll go ahead and
print that out and if I run this you'll
see that my list has all the values but
the second I convert it to a set which
is a special kind of tuple that doesn't
let you repeat values you'll see that it
gets rid of all my duplicates so now I
have 1 3 4 5 in there in my set so now
we've looked at a lot of different ways
to store our data in different variables
we have our list variable we had our
basic variables we had our two Bowl we
showed you how to do a set let's start
doing something with this information
we'll start with arithmetic operators
the most basic ones plus minus divide
let's just take a look and see what that
looks like we'll need some variables to
play with so we can look through the
basics and if you remember we did a
comma B equals or B equals a comma
be and all that we can actually do a
comma B equals 10 comma 5 that's nothing
more than what we already did just a
little different formatting what I'm
saying is the a equals to 10 the B
equals the 5 that's all that is and I
could write that out a equals 10 B
equals 5 just as easily and our basic
arithmetic operators you're gonna see is
we have a plus B I'll do this control
copy to bracket around it so we have our
a plus B set up on here and if we run
this we should get what we expect a plus
B 10 plus 5 equals 15 and we can do that
all kinds of different ways fact if we
look at all the basic operators let me
just do it now let's keep it this way we
can take this we have instead of a plus
B we'll do a minus B and let me grab
that and put that over here and let me
just go down this and do them all in one
shot there we go paste them right in
there and mostly you should be pretty
familiar the first four are your a plus
B a minus B a times B a divided by B and
so we look at that we get a plus B is 15
a minus B is 5 10 minus 5 is 5 multiply
we get 50 a divided by B gives us 2.0
and now we had kind of an unusual one we
have a double slash B 2 what this is
saying is that if there's a remainder
this is converted to an integer remember
I was telling you earlier I sometimes
have to slice my data so into thirds
instead of going length divided by 3 I
could do length / / / 3 and that gives
me an integer and it just tells me hey
where's my first third of data in
where's that at but if you do that you
also want to know what the remainder is
so that's what the amber sign is is a or
percentage sign that's what the
percentage sign is a percentage sign B
equals zero and then finally you can
square it and whoops I forgot to put
that as a to data science you tend to do
a lot of squaring you do like the square
means error so it's very common to see
something to the power of two and so
you'll see that a x times two gives you
u squared value this is actually BD
square is 25
5 times 5 is 25 so these are your basic
arithmetic operators there's really with
the first four there's no so
prizes you just have a surprise here
when you do a double slash because it
returns the integer and just drops the
decimal when you have the percentage
sign it Turk gives you just the return
value so 5.5 comes back as 0.5 and then
you have your double star is your
squared so B double star 2 is squaring
your value and we can take any of these
functions and assign them so I could do
rez as my variable equals a plus B and
then rez now becomes equal to a plus B
which should be 15 when I run it and
sure enough there's my 15 so now I can
take a and B and they might come in from
all kinds of different areas and set
another variable that goes out to
wherever needs it returns it to the
other part of the program as rez and
again this is true whether we do a plus
B a times B a divided by B any of those
basic functions is going to give us the
set the variable rez to that now we can
also do what they call shorthand for a
lot of this so we'll do counts the most
common one you do a count equal zero
because you want to know runs the
process adds one to it runs a process as
run to it so we can do count equals
count plus one and then if I print count
you'll see right here we get County goes
count plus 1 I get 1 0 plus 1 is 1 I can
also do we'll just do it up here count
equals but instead of putting the equals
they're going to put plus equals 1 and
this means they take count and I might
as well put the count here and the plus
sign and we can run that and you'll see
it now equals 2 so I get count equals
count plus one count plus equals one is
the same thing so I've added another one
to it and now I have two and we can
actually do this with anything and any
of the main I can do count times equal
so it's self times one and of course one
times one is one so I'll do something a
little bit more exciting like 1 times 3
and I get 3 and we could do this instead
of with count let's do a divide equals 2
and that's print a if we run that we get
5 so I've taken a which is 10 I've
divided it by 2 8 divided by 2 is 10 and
again any of these operators that we
just looked at I can now do down here
there's the integer version
can do the percentage sign run that has
a zero remainder so that's what comes up
with it maybe remember I was doing
thirds if we do thirds we can see I get
a remainder of one if I do divide a
divided by three
there's my 3.3333 very common but then I
can also do the double divide and I get
just my 3 out of there so a whatever
your rhythmatic operator goes here
equals three is is the same as a equals
a whatever operator you put there in the
3 so we had our basic arithmetic
operators we would look at relationship
or relational operators and whenever you
think of relationship think true/false
is this true or is it false and again we
can do our print will go a comma B just
so we have it down here take this out
take 3 my palate a little bit there and
so we have our 10 5 and then we can do a
print a is greater than B and if you're
listening closely I said think
true/false is a greater than B is 10
greater than 5 and if we run that we get
true and if you remember we did with
rhythmatic and you wonder where I'm
going with this you'll see that we have
all of our basic operators we have a is
greater than B a is less than B a is
greater than or equal to B a is greater
than or is less than or equal to B a
equals B notice it's double equal sign a
little different there and then we have
an asterisk on the bottom so let's go
ahead and run this and you can see down
here is a greater than B true is a
lesson B that's false
is a greater than or equal to B it's
still going to be true is a less than or
equal to B still going to be false and
then a double equal sign well because
the equal sign is used in Python to set
variables and to set values whenever you
do a logic where you want to know if
it's equal you have to use the double
equal sign that's very important and of
course is a equal to B the answer is
false
remember double equal sign and then if
you're going to have an equals you
should have a not equals so here's our
naught which is the exclamation point
and you can see that a is not equal to B
equals true so as we go through here we
have our logical our basic relational
operators which are logic gates on here
we can take this up a notch to do this
let me just go ahead and create a little
bit of different data here and in this
case I'm going to create an a1 b1 c1
equal to 10 20 30 and of course we print
those out as you guessed it it should be
just those values individually take this
clear my palette a little bit and run
that you see we get 10 20 30 down here
and if we pop up this is where it kind
of gets interesting is we're going to
print we're gonna use the same operators
we were just using but we're gonna do
c1 greater than a 1 we're gonna add an
extra logic in here and see 1 is greater
than B 1 so I'm asking your c1 equals 30
is it greater than 10 and and is it
greater than 20 and if I run that we get
true because that you know it is C 1 is
greater than a 1 C 1 is greater than B 1
now what happens if we had a 1 is
greater than B 1 and C wants greater
than B 1 well if we run this we're gonna
end up with false because a 1 is not
greater than V 1 but we can instead of
an we can do or so if I run this I will
now get true because C 1 is still
greater than B 1 so there's our or value
and you can stack these I could do a 1
greater than B 1 or C 1 B 1 you could
end up with a very lengthy logic
statement at some point you got to avoid
that you have to find another means to
do that but those are two basic ones as
and and or and then finally not so I can
take any of these logic gates and I can
change them from a 1 is greater than B 1
to not a ones not greater than B 1 so is
a 1 greater than B 1 know this would
return false but then we just reverse it
with the not and it comes out as true so
let's go ahead and clear this and we're
gonna look at very complicated I don't
know if it's really complicated we're
gonna touch upon what easily becomes a
complicated subject which is bitwise
operators in Python so you can imagine
let's just go back to notice it we had
our a B 10 and 5 so let's go back there
and pull that back in here so we're
gonna have our two variables a B 10 and
5 and we're gonna look at bit wise
operators to understand the bitwise
operator let's go ahead and print binary
of a go ahead and do the binary of
we're not going to dig too deep into
this I just want you to be aware of it
for more advanced programming and you'll
see it comes out of here here's the bit
value which is your one zero one zero
and this would be all zeros up until
there that's what the zero B means it's
binary and everything else on this side
is zero and this is the same thing five
is represented by 101 ten is represented
by 10 10 in binary when you switch it
over so we look at this binary switches
we're gonna do that we can go let's do
print a and B so if we run this we end
up with zero and it's kind of
interesting because how that could they
get zero out of that you know this is 10
10 and 101 well if you lend this up this
one on the right hand side lines up with
the 0 so guess what that's 0 we take
this 0 we line it up with this 0 and
guess what we get we get 0 there's no an
it's not the same value and we have 1
and 0 so we are doing a if this equals
this if this equals this and if this
equals this we get print a which prints
out was it print out zero because none
of the match and we can do something
like print a and you use the up down bar
and unless you do a lot of work with
this you almost always have to look it
up if you're dealing with binary number
or with shifts and things like that or
for these decimal places it are and so
we're going to do a or B if we run that
we get 15 and if we print let's just
print this in binary so you can see what
that looks like so if we print a or B in
binary let's run that so remember up
here we got 0 I forgot to convert print
print let's try that again
let's print this in binary and if we
print this in binary you'll see now that
it's an or so we have 1 or 1 equals 1 0
1 0 or 1 equals 1 1 or 0 equals 1 it
gets kind of confusing there but you can
see where if either one has a 1 in its
place or a thing comes out as 1 and so
we get 1 1 1 1 and it does turn out that
when you print this out it came out as
15 so if you do a binary or statement on
these two numbers you get 15 on there
and we can do this we can continue this
down there are exclusive so we can do
print and we'll do this
of A or B we'll do an exclusive which is
your tilled up we can run that and it's
going to return the same thing because
this is exclusively one so if this had
been one one one one and this has been
one zero one zero we would have seen the
one zero one zero come through on the
exclusive where the or it returns all
one's and if you have exclusive you can
also have ones complement so this would
be like negating your number so we can
do just do this binary and this is the
other squiggly of a and we run that and
we'll see that this googley comes out as
101 one so it reverses it it's a little
different on this because we are looking
at a ones complement on there so it
changes your logic thinking on there and
this you do a lot of work with it can
really tie your brain and it's kind of
fun to figure out if you play with it
and then finally we have a couple more
cool things you can do this this we can
do print we can do with the collar shift
and I'll gonna put this in binary
because it's really hard to make sense
of it if you're not doing binary and we
can do shift to this shifts it to the
left so you can see right here we've
added two zeros on the right hand side
to our a and we have the same number and
it shifted it all to the left and we can
also shift it the other way shift it
this way and we can run that and now we
just shift it off and these two just get
bumped off and we end up with the last
two digits the one zero so we're
shifting everything to to the right
whoops I'm sorry we dropped the one zero
did it backwards since we're shifting it
to the right we lose this one zero and
we end up with just this first one zero
and this is when you get into like a
huge array of true/false yes/no and you
need to compare them and you can do all
kinds of cool things in here again it's
a very advanced logic when you're doing
bitwise operators but it's important to
know they're there and understand what
they are so when it does come up you
know where to look for them and finally
talking about logic we'll need to go
ahead and look at membership operators
very useful thing to have let's just do
a list equals we'll do one two back
there one two three four five so we have
our basic list and the question is let's
assign a variable X
x equals two and so let's go print X in
list and what do you think that's going
to print is X in the list is two in
there and the answer is yes so we get
true so it's going to print true in
there and you can remember we can also
add the not in there is X not in list we
run that and equals false and when we
start looking later on here or shortly
at our if-else lists and wireless you'll
see where this comes in handy to get
these true/false statements on here and
then we have identity operator clear our
palette identity operator and this is
all let's do x equals 10 y equals 10 and
this print X is y if we run this we get
true because remember when python points
to the memory it stores the 10 in the
same place and so X is y and if we
change this to y equals 12
it will now give us a false because
they're no longer equal so and you could
also replace this with X and don't do a
lot of X what is y it does come up so
you need to be aware of it but it's not
usually just do x equals y false but X
is why I changed it 12 so again false
and then you can also go in here X is
not Y so is y or is not Y and it's true
it is not Y so these are all the basic
functions with netic functions that you
find with your Python installed so we're
going to cover next is what happens if
it's not in there what happens if you
have some more complicated math
equations you need to run well at that
point you got to import math so the
import it's important to know what the
import is for have an external module to
python so it's not part of the basic
Python code you import that module in
math it's used so much that they have it
bundled with the Python install but by
default it doesn't load into your IDE
into your user face or into the program
so when you go to use math you have to
run the import on there and let's just
take a look and see what some of the
stuff that math covers now I did a quick
Bing search and it took me to Python
this is always nice because we have the
actual version
here which version of Python you're in
the documentation Python and then we
went to the math module and in the math
module we have ceiling we have copied
the sign fabs factorial floor ceiling
and floor kind of interesting this is
really from an external viewpoint its
rounding up or rounding down but there's
other things that go on behind the
scenes that you might use this instead
and then there's here's our basic
functions and if you scroll down you can
see it just covers all kinds of
different things like is it finite is it
infinite is it an and modify F powers so
if we were doing exponential we saw how
to square a value but if you wanted to
do something to the third or the fourth
you have to import the math module to do
that and you can see here where we have
exponential of 1 this is like
exponential X minus 1 log X all your log
functions are in here square root
there's one that comes up a lot in data
science if you're gonna take the square
means of a value for your error cosine
signs tangents all the different
trigonometric functions all this is in
the math and really we're not going to
cover all the different things you can
do in math cuz that's its own domain if
you're working with degrees and radians
or hyperbolic functions there's just a
lot in the math module including
mathematical constant e dau infinite nan
pi there's your PI in there so all this
stuff is in your math module and when
we're in here we can do something simple
like print math PI if I run this should
give me the value of Pi which it does
3.14 1 so on any of the functions in
here if you import math you could import
something like this you could import
another option let's say I wanted just
the PI value we could do something like
this we could also do from maths that
tells it to go to the math module import
PI if we do this we don't need the math
in front of it so we're just importing
the PI and I can run this and now you
can see I have PI here same thing we can
do all the functionality that you saw
earlier let's go back to import math and
instead of Pi let's go ahead and do
couldn't do a variable so we could put
in x equals 9.5 and then from here from
our math you can do if you remember from
the very top they had the ceiling which
I said was the same as rounding it up it
could do print
sealing of X and if I run this it should
give us ten so sealing is actually the
nearest integer that's greater than nine
point five you could also do again
there's a cosine tangent all of these
functionalities are in your math module
let's see what tangent looks like 0.075
three there you go then there's a couple
that I see regularly in the coding one
is power so I could do x equals nine
point five y equal to stick to three and
we can do X to the Y or X cubed and we
can see we get eight hundred fifty seven
point three seven five I use the power
when I'm trying to figure out how long
it's gonna take to run certain programs
especially when you're going through a
lot of permutations you might find
yourself go ahead okay I got three
permutations and each permutation has
three different variations well that's
three to the three so if I run it once
through I can guess at the time it's
going to run by doing three to the three
and then I can just program it to guess
at my time output is one other one is of
course square root so we can do the
square root of that's another very
common one square root especially in
data science when you're computing the
error we do the square root of x so we
can do the square root as qrt of x if i
run this i'll print the square root
again you know data science the square
root means error there's your square
root factorials that's another one of
those things that come up probably not
as much but if we're doing the factorial
we'll do why this time and we run it
this is adding up all the numbers up to
three so this is one plus two plus three
and it equals six again those are just a
few of the different mathematical
functions you can do and you can go over
to python and see the full slew of them
on the website so so far we've looked at
datatype storing data math functions so
some things that you can do with the
data that comes in let's go ahead and
cover another area we're gonna go into
input and well look at this is a very
basic way of inputting data and more
specifically in line input so this is
not your Windows interface or frames
interface or windows XY interface and
there is interfaces for Python whether
you're exporting it into an HTML or some
other format that then feeds the data
back into Python there's a lot of
different options there
this specifically is just in line and
what that means is we need to find a way
to get the data in so we'll do name
input there's our input command and then
the first part is the prompt this is
what it's gonna prompt you for it says
enter your name and we'll add a scoop I
like to call it but backward slash in
this case in this stands for new line
that's what this little these two
symbols next to each other is and the
backward slash is a scape key so if you
actually need to put a variable in with
the backward slash like I want enter
slash your it's to enter get your name
this will print a backward slash and
this will prompt us for our name if I
hit enter you'll see inter get your name
and when I click down here type in
Richard which is my name and hit enter
then it continues the code on there and
then we can do something with this we
can do print and we'll do hi comma name
and remember with the print this is
simply prints whatever the first one is
comma the second one comma and so on and
so I can now hit this in here I'm gonna
go down here proxy for my name enter get
your name maybe gets kind of a weird way
of putting it hi Richard we'll change
this from get to enter and put and we
might continue on down here so we'll go
ahead and do input age I'll do age
equals input enter your age I will do
the same backward slash in and this time
instead of printing the age we're gonna
enter in an integer this is kind of a
very important thing to know when you're
doing Lion inputs if I run this and we
print type of the age let's just go
ahead and go through this and show
Richard that's gonna say hi Richard
enter your age won't put down my real
age well say I'm a young 25 so
significantly less than my age and this
is interesting because it takes the
input and it's a string that's what this
class string means so whenever you do an
input like this it comes in as a string
and that's important to know because if
you're trying to add age to something
it's not going to come out very good an
error so I could do print age plus 5
because age is a string when I come in
here and I just do this really
misspelled my word my name type error
must be string not integer so it's
trying to add 5 which is an integer to a
string which you can't do so that's very
important when you're coding you start
getting those kinds of errors that's
where they're coming from is you got
sure your two types match and one way I
mean you can convert it and if you
remember from conversions I can simply
put integer age
well beheaded your age plus one just to
see how it's different and it will
convert it to age or to a number on here
to an integer we enter in our name the
inter in all pretend age and you'll see
that it now is able to add one to that
age because I've converted it to an
integer you gotta be a little careful
with this because you might have
characters in there that aren't integer
in which case we'll give you an error at
that point let's do two more things with
this let's go ahead and print with a
format so we have name and age and let's
say we'll do first formatting and we'll
put in an S in there is second formatted
word years old and if you remember from
the formatting we can now take this at
our amber sign at the end or a
percentage and then we put the two
variables name and age in here and then
I go ahead and run this and if we run
this here if we run this I can type in
my name type in my pretend age if you
said tuple you've got that right so
you're gonna remember I'm sending it as
a tuples with the curb brackets do to it
so now we run this it should give me a
nice format on there so it looks pretty
sometimes that's really important
because people are coming in see this
all the time instead of these nice forms
that come up we used to see it where it
do prompts like this for people coming
in and we'll see that we get an error
down here because de looks for a decimal
we have two strings so we could do
something like this integer age now if I
run it I shouldn't have any errors on
there I should come in here when they
fall and there we go Richard is 25 years
old and so we did a couple things in
here we now have our formatting we now
have string versus decimals with the D
stands for that's pretty much any number
and make sure we give it a number so we
have a set up on there and you would
probably want to double-check their
input if this was for a forum fill out
or something like that although this
usually I use this for small programs
where I'm testing something out and I
got to put a different input in each
time and use them very often but it does
come up and does come up where you might
need to test something real quick or
have a line input for a very long script
you're running and they just need a
simple line input and one of the last
things we can do on here so we can take
this
and let's say instead of enter input
name how about a word and we're gonna do
on this word if you remember from before
we had our indexes for our list well a
word of any kind is nothing more than a
string of characters and that string is
stored in a list so I can come in here
and take name and I can say hey I just
want the first four letters of that of
your name maybe that's what it is and
we'll print let's just keep it name
maybe you're creating a username or a
reference I've seen this where they have
passwords and things like that said to
the first four letters I hit enter it's
gonna return rich just the first four
letters and that's because this index
works just like it does in a list it's
the same index as it is a list before we
move on to the next section one more
thing I want to note about input a
equals can't adjure if you remember
correctly we did a conversion where if
you had the number number in here 3 a
character this converts it to an integer
gives you an error if you put a in there
we can also do this as a single line
this is very common in Python to try to
bring stuff together they call it the
Python way just makes it a little easier
to read let's say you can see right here
into a multiple of two five in this case
this actually converts it so if I go
ahead and put in down here print a we
run this to 5 you get 5 and if I type in
the type of a you will of course see the
dist of type integer I'll just go ahead
and run this real quick print 5 class
integer so this is just a way of
combining the conversion with the input
you can put it all in one line like this
take it nice and compact so what we want
to cover next is the if statements and
there's like the if the else the LF
we're also gonna start into the loops
we're going to cover the while statement
which uses the logic gate in the loop
and then we'll look at the for our for
statement which is just a loop without
logic and of course there's a couple of
odds and ends break and continue which
go with the loops so the if statement
this is where we started doing something
with the data we're putting in so you'll
see here I went ahead did input enter
multiple of five and maybe we want to
know if it is a multiple of five so if
hey how can we do that we can do a
divided by five and get the remainder
off of that is not equal to zero so it's
a little simple logic there this returns
true false if we remember we covered all
that true/false statements so if it's
not equal to zero then it doesn't then
if it's equal to zero it has no
remainder so it's multiple of five if
it's not equal to zero it has a
remainder which means that it is then
not a multiple of five and we can just
simply have a print and we'll just uh
well do this we go a comma not a
multiple of five and if I run this and I
enter in let's just enter in three three
not a multiple of five and if we have
another piece of code down here we'll
just print this is what happens next so
we might have some more script down here
and if we run that we enter in five it
just goes right down to this is what
happens next and if we go back we put in
four you'll see that four comes up and
says four is not a multiple of five this
is what happens next and so the if
statement only runs if this is true and
it runs whatever is indented so here's
our colon and here's our indent Python
is very big on the end it's that's how
it tells what piece of code is different
from the next other languages use
different like a semicolon for Java if
you're in HTML you have to put a block
at the beginning at the end so every a
different scripting language has its own
set up and this is how Python does it
you do an indent right there so make
sure you're very careful we are indents
are and then let's go ahead and just do
enter a number and if you can do an if
statement we can also have else
statement and the else occurs print a so
if I wanted to know is this is even or
odd we could do this I could do if a
divided by two the remainder of that is
not equal to zero then this is going to
be what odd so this is odd number this
is an even number just some basic logic
there and if we run this I can now come
down here and turn four it says four is
an even number and then this is what
happens next and we can also do this if
I enter in a five five this is an odd
number so just some basic logic so you
can see right here
either it is even either it is odd the
remainder is not equal to two
else whatever's next and the only other
option is it's even now this may be good
if you're just doing a simple you have
two choices we can also do the L if
statement and we put that in before the
else statement L if and then of course
we have our logic here and we'll go
ahead and combine some logic we can do a
couple things here let's go back up to
this and our number a copy in our number
will have a number a B and C so we'll go
ahead and have three different choices
take out this last line and so the first
choice we want to know is is a the
greatest value so we could do a is
greater than B and a is greater than C
so if a is greater than a and a is
greater than B a is the greatest number
so we have this over here and if we have
that we can have LF we can do let's say
B B is greater than a and B is greater
than C we'll go ahead and do this we'll
do a print statement print B V is the
greatest number and if a is not the
greatest number and B is not the
greatest number that leaves one other
option so go down to our else statement
and we'll have else C is the greatest
number and if we run this code here we
enter a number one or one two three this
is three is the greatest number and of
course if we run this code again you do
three two one and it gives me an error
because I accidentally hit a character
string they're three - 32 - so if we do
this and we do three two one we still
get three is the greatest number and
finally we could put it right in the
middle and it's just still pull it out
we could do one three two and I'll still
come up with three is the greatest
number you can actually go take this as
far as you want so we have just here the
three choices you could have if-else
if-else there are other ways to do that
when you get more than here but for
basic Python this covers most of the
program you're doing with the else and
the else if statement as far as the
logic statements involved in there the
last thing we want to really look at is
a nested if an else statement and we can
do that we'll keep the get rid of some
of this stuff on the screen clear our
screen here and we can do is we
can go enter let's do it enter your age
and we'll call the variable age up here
so we're gonna enter the age and we want
to know oh let's say this is are you
available for a certain discount maybe
it's a bus fare discount maybe it's you
get a discount for a restaurant or
something like that so we're having here
we enter your age and if a let's do a is
greater than 64 so if a is greater than
64 we put our colon in there and this is
actually age print I will print you are
eligible for senior citizen discount and
maybe will be a little nice so make it
if your greater than 60 how about
greater than or equal to 60 we're really
feeling generous so if your age is
greater than or equal to 60
you're gonna discount else will print
you're not eligible for a discount well
go ahead just run this real quick and so
if you are 66 come up you're eligible
for a discount and if you put in 40 it
will say you're not eligible for a
discount and then we come along we
realize oh hey we have discount also for
people who are under a certain age we
have our youth discount so we'll go
ahead and come in here and we'll say oh
if your age is less than 18
let's do less than or equal to 19 less
than or equal to 18 print and then of
course we can do see you are eligible
for a minor discount or youth discount
and then we need to come in here if we
want to do this if age is less than 18
since it's nested we're doing else here
and if I put the else down here a couple
things to notice about this list so we
have our first statement if age is
greater than or equal to 60 you're
eligible for a senior citizen discount
and then we put the else so any logic
whatever happens under this else this is
always gonna go if I move this else back
out I'll give me an error because you
can't have two else States and certainly
you can do this as an LF statement here
too so this is kind of another way of
doing an LF statement sometimes you want
to add some let's put a note here
sometimes you might have additional
script here so before you can do these
two calculations you might have to do
some kind of calculation here that's why
you want to do a nested if an else
statement instead of using the FL F and
L statement and we can see here if I run
this in
your age now if you enter the age nine
you're eligible for a minor discount and
of course if what we did before we have
somebody who's 56 you are not eligible
for any discount and of course if you're
64 or 60 or older you get that nice
senior citizen discount and if you were
listening to earlier no I don't qualify
for the senior citizen discount quite
yet although I do look forward to it the
next thing we want to start covering is
our loops and we have the while and for
loop and so the while loop utilizes your
logic to let it know when did how many
times to loop through let's go ahead and
take a look and see what that script
comes out as we can do is let's go ahead
and take a word equals to Austin Python
since that's what we're programming in
and let's do I equals 0 let's say while
I is less than or equal to 5 and since
this is we use that indent just like we
did the FL statement we still need that
indent in the colon there while I is
less than or equal to 5 let's go ahead
and print word and then we're gonna do i
if you remember correctly we're gonna
increment it by 1 we can do a plus
equals 1 same as I equals I plus 1 so I
plus equals 1 and if we run this we'll
come down here and you'll see it repeats
the Python in this case 5 times and we
can even do something like this let's do
a comma word and let's run that and
you'll see we get 0 1 2 3 4 5 one of the
things always to be aware of is we did I
is less than or equal to 5 if this was
an actual length of the array
you would have array out of bounds
because remember you don't want to
include the length of the range of 0 to
4 so a lot of times just remember unless
you actually wanted to print 0 through 5
we can do while I is less than 5 print I
I plus or equals 1 and then we get our 0
1 2 3 4 Python now there's other ways to
do a loop like this and I'll show you in
just a minute with the for loop this
just gives you an idea here's our true
false statements and just like we did
before you could have if I is less than
5 or I is less than 8 which would kind
of be redundant but you could have your
or and and and you could have a very
lengthy logic gate right here
long as it returns true or false so we
use the while because we don't know how
many loops you want to go through on
here in this case we actually set it to
five but maybe we're building a list and
let's just go ahead and do this we'll do
a list we create an empty list
let's get an input and we'll we'll call
it C this is inner one to add elements
to list and zero to exit to loop the
while loop we've created a variable and
then an enter here and the input if you
remember correctly we're not converting
this to an integer so we're going to
just go ahead and keep it as a character
so we're gonna say while C does not
equal and because it's a character we
gotta put and put the brackets around it
to let it know it's going to be a string
the string of 0 so long as this doesn't
equal 0 keep doing and then we're gonna
do here on our while loop as we're gonna
have another input here and on here
we're gonna have input enter an element
to add to the list that's the input
integer this one isn't it would just
keep it as and rate input I kind of like
that keep it uniform on there and what
we can do let me just go ahead and copy
this up here so we're gonna start adding
elements and the order in which we do
this is always important you never know
how your loops gonna go I switch that
around because I want to append to my
list C so whatever we enter in and the
first one gets appended to the list and
then we ask for the next one if the next
one is 0 so whatever we type in there's
going to be added to the element and the
order as I was saying is important
because if we put this after the second
input whatever you put in here is going
to ignore and if we put it before that's
going to keep adding it in until you put
0 in the z-row if you put this after the
0 it will still add the 0 in so you'll
end up with the 0th into the list so by
putting it before this input we're gonna
have both the first input going in and
whatever input we add in and to get a
view of what this looks like let's go
ahead and print our list when we run
that you'll see it comes up it says
enter 0 to quit and other to add to list
but I can add an a an we can add a 3 in
a T remember I didn't put any bounds on
it and making it a managed or anything
like that and I'll put the 0 and when I
put the 0 there it is a 3 and T
so this while loop keeps going until it
hits something that says okay we're done
and then it just kicks it out so it
finishes the loop comes back up here
says is this true if it's true
we do it again if it's false then we
skip out of the loop and then it
continues on down below where we printed
the list now if you remember from
earlier we had the I plus 1 and we just
loop through to print Python out four
times certainly there's better ways to
do that instead of adding all that math
in there and we can do that so word
equals so we can do that real just
simply by doing a for loop for doesn't
require logic we do for we'll do W in
range 10 and let's go ahead and print W
comma word and if I run this we'll see
we have Python printed ten times let me
just take that down a notch since my
screen display doesn't show up as much
so arrange three and if you remember
from earlier range does 0 to 3 but
doesn't include 3 I could just as easily
put 0 comma 3 in here and I'll get the
same answer and you can also add a step
on there there's a lot of controls you
can add with range so we can print W
range of 3 when that's pretty cool just
prints word over and over and over again
well we could also do with this is we
can create a list so I can create my
list
there's our square brackets and we could
do one too let's add hello well that a
sub list which is one two three and so
we can do on this is I could do instead
of a range I could do object in list so
for object and list I want to print just
the object and if we run this you'll see
down here we have one two hello and then
it printed to the one that's sub list
the whole sub list in there one two
three because one object in there so it
just iterates through each entity in the
list and prints it right out what we can
do next is we can kind of combine some
of these so you've seen the for loop we
have our if statements along with some
different logic gates we can do so we
can do let's do this let's go word
equals input and this to enter word so
we're gonna get a word from you off of
your keyboard
let's do count equals zero and we're
just going to count vowels we're going
to
a loop to count the number of vowels in
word so for I N word remember from
before we can iterate through each
object and when you do a string so if we
have if our word was equal Python we
have py th o in each one of those is an
object in that list that's an actual
list so we enter the word that's a list
of letters so this is just going to go
through and look at each one of those
letters and we're gonna say hey if I n
will give it an array if it's a AEIOU or
capital a capital e capital i capital o
couple you these are seen differently
they're very different characters on
there we have our our colon here this
lets us know we need to indent at this
point we know it's a canal so we want to
go ahead and count plus equals 1 and
then we just want to go down here and
say print number of vowels in o let's do
a little formatting s is the if remember
we got to create that little tuple at
the end with all the different values
and so here is our word and our count so
let's go ahead and run this and for the
word I'll go ahead and enter in count
and we can see the number of vowels and
count is two and sure enough it's got a
no u in it and if we run this again and
let's do counting we can see that
there's three vowels in there oh you and
I now when we're talking about loops
both the while loop and the for loop and
this works actually on any the
continuing break will work any kind of
indent so even the if statement I could
add a break partway through the if
statement and it will kick it out so
that's important to know but we want to
know about break and continue and how
those work so let's go ahead and create
a little script here so we take a look
at it and break is just like you think
it is whatever it's doing it stops it it
breaks the flow so let's go ahead and do
this we're gonna do range two comma the
integer of n divided by two plus one
we're gonna look for prime numbers we'll
see if we can figure out how to find a
prime number and so what we have going
here is I'm gonna take in which equals
49 and help me find the prime number
we're gonna go all the way through see
in range 2 to n divided by 2 we
to add one to it now for the first part
we don't really need to add the 1 but
I'm going to show you in a minute that
for another piece of code we can put the
1 in so I'm just gonna leave that in
there and we're going to divide by each
of those eyes so I is equal to 2 3 4 5 6
all the way up to 25 so it's basically 2
to 25 and we want to take the and we
want to divide by that but we want to
know if there's a remainder that's how
we can tell if it's a prime number
because if it has no remainder
then we have a prime number so n divided
by I the remainder of it if that equals
0 and this is not a prime number so
we'll print this is not a prime number
instead of this is well just go ahead
and do well let's just do something
simple in here's not a prime number
there we go now if we picked a number
like 20 it will get to 4 and print this
is not a prime number
it'll get to 5 this is not a prime
number it will get to 10 this is not a
prime number it's gonna print that three
times we don't want it to keep printing
that we want to stop you let's say hey
we got an answer it's not a prime number
break and if we go ahead and run this we
should get 49 it's not a prime number
it's divisible by 7 we do know that oh
the number 11 is a prime number so if I
run this it'll just go through the code
and say ok we're good this is the kind
of thing you might do if you have an
input and you're checking the input to
make sure they're valid inputs you want
to come up and say hey this isn't a
valid input kick it out or if it's a
valid input go ahead and do the process
on there and if you're gonna have break
we also need to look at continue and how
that works and so let's say instead of
looking for a prime number I want to
know all the different numbers that
divide into the number I wanna know what
it's divisible by and so we can do that
let's do if it's not equal to VIN
divided by I is not equal to 0 I want it
to continue else what I want to do is I
want to print let's do our place marker
well do D is visible by this is also
going to be a number so we'll do another
D for decimal then of course if you do
this part we got to have our two pull on
the end and in this case we want to do
our number n is divisible by our number
so let's take a look and see what's
going on with this code continue unlike
just says hey here we have our loop or
it could be a while statement for
statement so here we have our loop I get
two here and it says okay if this Manor
does not equal zero I don't want to do
anything after this I just want to go
back to the top of the loop and so it
skips this line down here it's like an
else statement right here else do this
so this is one way you can almost put an
else statement here instead so I can run
this and it says press is finished
because 11 happens to be a prime number
we'll set it to 20 since I brought up
that earlier I will see that 20 is
divided by 2 is divisible by 4 it's
divisible by 5 by 10 it just goes right
down the list so this gives you an idea
of how you can utilize the continue when
you're in one of these loops to use that
logic to help you get the script to do
what you want it to do the next topic we
want to cover is going to be some more
advanced modules as you get more and
more advanced in Python you really are
starting to look at all these great
modules that are developed by third
parties one of the greatest drinks in
Python is you get a module to do almost
anything and two of the modules we want
to look at our arrays and numpy these
are in data science they're so important
for storing information and manipulating
it and the difference between an array
because we have remember we did lists
remember lists from before our list they
equal within the brackets and a lot of
times you'll you might have caught me
once or twice hopefully you didn't but
you probably did where I call the list
an array in Python they're not the same
thing that's very important to note
because the list is a base Python list
of objects where the array is a special
module you bring in and you got to be
careful when you're talking about other
programming languages an array is what a
list is in Python so you might hear that
terminology they probably have some
other programming languages and they do
have a lot of similarities so we're
gonna do from array import star so we're
gonna import everything we have from the
array setup that's all this meets so
from our array we're importing all the
different sub modules in it you could
probably just get by with import array
at this point because I would do a
similar thing but we will let you know
that there is a difference there and we
do an array we just use the array
command code and then we can create the
array inside the brackets and just like
a list we can do all kinds of things
with this as far as mix and match but
one of the nice things about array I can
also tell it it has to be of a specific
type
so in this array here I'm designating
these are all integers sin to it a list
of integers 1 2 3 4 5 and if we print
the type of the array you should see it
come down here and it says ok class
array array has finished so the class is
always going to be an array on here and
this particular array might designate it
as integers we can also do on our print
just like you have like your regular
array you can access the integers by
their index number so we'll put in 2 if
we print the array of index 2 will see
that it points to 3 so it's just like a
list so far so far it has all the
different setups you would as a list on
here and this includes a pinned so I
could actually take this and I could go
array append minus 10 we'll run that
just print out the whole array and we'll
see you now we have our an array of type
I 1 2 3 4 5 - 10 something just to pin
just like we did so in other words all
the functionality you have on your list
you're gonna find you have with the
array we'll just go ahead and do a
couple more like that so you can see
what that looks like
let's go ahead and remove 3 so if I
remove the value 3 from here you'll see
1 2 4 5 - 10 if we want to go ahead and
print well you saw I printed the index
the first time we can also do an actual
index minus 10 on the array let's go
ahead and run that and we get 4 this is
kind of interesting because if I did
this with a list I would get an error by
doing the index minus 10 so we have
minus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and it just
kind of loops over until it gets to the
3 but where arrays are different than
lists and this is so important this is
what makes an array an array
we'll take this back here and just print
the array on here I could do something
like this a are equals AR times 3 and if
I run this you'll see right here my
array has now jumped and so when I do AR
times 3 the array is now 2 4 5 - 10
and repeats it three times so this is
one of the cool things you can do with
an array on here now at this point if
you're doing a lot of functionality on
your array you'll almost always end up
in numbers Python so even though there's
a lot of really cool things especially
the type settings you can actually have
it all integers really in this
particular module you want numpy which
sits on top of array and probably the
most common form you see it you'll see
import numpy as in P now you can just do
import numpy and wherever you see in PU
use numpy now if you are you'll see when
I run this I get an error cuz I opened
up a new project in PyCharm that means
all my modules that are added in
externally aren't there if you are
working IDE you might go to the command
line and do a pip install numpy and that
will bring it in if you're using pip
there's a number of different install
packages if you're using Jupiter
notebooks under khandha or anaconda it's
Khanda install Conda does the same thing
as pip except that it's brings in all
the different sub packages that's the
most common one your pip install but
we're in python hi charm and so in pi
try we want to go up to click on that
file once we're on file we want to go
down to settings once for under settings
we want to go under our project and then
you'll see project interpreter this is
really cool that we're actually in here
because you can see underneath here
we're using Python 3 6 so if I had a
role out in a different version I could
go in here and add those versions in and
switch them around I just have the one
on this particular machine and I go over
here to the plus sign on the right hand
side and I click on there and then for
installing in here well type in numpy
and once I have numpy you'll see there's
different versions and numpy on here
generally we would ignore all of those
unless you're doing something special
and go right to the one that's just
straight numpy and then click on install
package then PyCharm will take over it
will install the nut be packaged into
this particular environment this is when
the beautiful things about using PyCharm
as it keeps this environment separate
from everything else and then once it's
installed we can now go back here
out of settings there's our numpy added
in there so now it shows me what I have
installed on here this is such a great
tool because I can see exactly what I'm
using in this environment and now when I
run it you'll see I don't get an error
for not having the module so you've got
to make sure the numpy module is
installed and this really is if you're
doing data science one of the
bread-and-butter tools you need is your
numpy set up your numpy array and we'll
go ahead and create our first numpy
array we'll call it a r1 equals NP dot
array so in p4 numpy dot array is the
command all this is doing one two three
some being a little boring as far as
what I'm putting in it and then let's go
ahead and just print that and see what
that looks like print this is an array
made with a list there's other ways to
make an array but we're just gonna print
our a r1 we put a list in there so we
just doesn't need to list into it and
then we print our a r1 and we see that
it comes out it looks just like a list
one of the catches is there's no commas
in here so if I wanted to go ahead and
let's say take our list and you're gonna
say why is this so important there's no
commas in there if you're doing a lot of
debugging and you see this first one you
know you're either in an array or a list
if you see the next one you know you're
in numpy so it's just kind of a quick
flag in the programming script and
debugging for some of the things you can
look for now the numpy array starts to
take a major shift here this is where
this becomes real important as far as
the setup we'll talk about shape and
sizes and matrixes here in just a second
let's go ahead and do this we're gonna
create two sub lists so remember that
from before we have list one list two
from then do that I do need to put
brackets around it this is a 2d sample
and you could look at this as being one
of the common things is XY coordinates
so I might have 1 2 3 4 X 4 5 6 for Y
and if we print that out you can see as
it comes down here in our AR 1 it prints
it out no commas but you have your two
different lists on here and we can do
something like this we can print
dimensions equals and then I'm going to
do AR 2 dot in dimensions so if we run
this you'll see it comes out with a add
a print or set up on there and it has
two dimensions and that's pretty easy to
see we have dimension 1 which is a 1 2 3
and dimension 2 which is 4 5 6 likewise
there's also saw
in shape and so if I do this sit-up on
here we can see that we can get the size
dimensions is two the size is six
just how many entities are in there and
then the shape this is I don't know how
many times I look at the shape of these
things because you're putting it through
some kind of format and if your shapes
don't match when you're doing machine
learning and you're doing a fit and a
train you'll get an error and so it's so
important to double-check your shape and
make sure it's correct make sure we have
a two by three matrix in this case and
then finally just like you can do this
with any of you know type command we can
also get the they call D type in numpy
so in your number array we'll see that
the type of elements is an integer 32 so
it actually returns what kind of
elements I have in here and they do they
all look like integers on there let's go
ahead and take a short detour here and
just take a look at the numpy official
side so if we go to the official numpy
site we'll see right off the top side
org which is the group behind it it's
all open source you can actually go in
here and donate to it and it's so
extensive I'm just gonna look at data
types and so data types gets its own tab
and you can see from here we were what
integer there are so many specialties
you can do with this and so they cover
just about every data type you can think
of there's our integer 32 so here's our
integer 32 that is the standard that's
usually what it converts to if you're
converting from directly from Python
into numpy but you can force it into any
of these two other different kind of
data types on here so it has a lot of
diverse use on this obviously we can't
cover everything under numpy there's a
ray creation and put output with numpy
indexing broadcasting byte swapping
structure to raise each one of these is
a significantly large topic it's its own
class if you will you can see right here
we're gonna do that we're trying to
cover just a couple things so you get a
little flavor of Numbi so let's take a
look at we have our numpy stuff going on
let's go ahead and look at filling an
array with zeros this comes up too
sometimes you want 0 as your placeholder
and so you begin your process with
filling it with zeros or 1
or other values and you can simply do in
P dot zeroes and then this is important
as it needs to know the dimensions we'll
do it two by two and we'll do it the
type equals there's our integer so we're
gonna fill it as integers on here let's
go ahead and take our Z and if we print
this out and run that you'll see that I
get a nice two-by-two array filled with
zero so maybe I'm doing plotting you
don't know what the plots are but I need
to have it prefilled a lot of test data
does this you can create your own data
and make stuff up and do all kinds of
things there once you have it preformed
at it and if we fill it with zeros we
can also do fill it with almost anything
so instead of zeros we'll do a full and
thus two two comma three and then
instead of this is to fill it with let's
do one and let's run this and when I run
this you'll see that I've created a two
by three array all filled with ones and
just like our list and everything else
we can come in here and we can access
the different indexes of our numpy array
in this case we're gonna do index 1
comma 2 and when I run that we get 6
where does 1 comma 2 come from well
remember we count from 0 so there's 0 1
and we count from 0 we get 0 1 2 and so
if we do this arrangement 1 comma 2 is
gonna be the row followed by the column
and just like any of these we can get
very complicated we can do something
like this we'll keep this as 1 and we
could also do so we'll do 1 we have our
comma but I want to do after the comma a
colon there then I'm gonna put in
another Colin and if you remember from
before that means we're gonna do a step
and let's do minus 1 so this would look
a little familiar this is the same kind
of format you got from list and if I run
this we're gonna look at the 1 so 0 1 4
5 6 I'm going to select all of them
that's what the first colon is and then
the second one says hey but I want to go
backwards we're gonna step minus 1 and
so we're going 6 5 4 on here that's why
you get the 6 5 4 and we could also do
something like this we could add in to 1
and if we run that you'll see that I get
3 to 1 because it doesn't include one
they can do up to 2 and then we get 3 2
one six five four so now we have that
the first two in Reverse zero and one
and you can just play with this
different ways to select different
entities in our numpy array and although
we can't dig into all the different
aspects of a numpy array I didn't want
to bring up one last thing which is
operations on a numpy array this is
pretty cool because I can take this and
here's our numpy array we've created we
can do something like this we can take
print array three and let's just add 10
to it and this is a little different
than what we've seen before so if I run
this and I add 10 to it we run it you'll
see it right adds 10 to every entity in
the array so I have 11 12 13 14 15 16
and so on
just adding 10 on there and likewise I
could do all kinds of different values
like times 10 so they're just multiplied
out by times 10 there is other
functionality like you can summit so we
can sum all the values in there you
could also select just a slice of this
so you could select well let's do the
first zero and then summit and so we get
6 1 plus 2 plus 3 is 6 so there's some
there's men there's max the slew of
commands just goes on and on and on
there's so much you can do with the
number array and some important things
to note there's also what they call
transpose and this comes in a lot when
you're graphing because you might have a
graph that looks at X Y let's go back to
our 2d array and it wants all of X Y but
your array came in as all the rows so
you have 1 comma 4 2 comma 5 3 comma 6
and you need to transpose it if I run
this you'll see that I've gone from 1 to
3 comma 4 5 6 to 1 4 to 5 3 6 tends to
be the other way around there's times
when you need the individual pairs and
of course we could go back and transpose
it go in the other way of course this
doesn't work because when you do this it
doesn't do it in place you have to let
it know it's in place if you're going to
do that us we'd have to do something
more like AR 3 equals AR transpose
take this T out and now we should get it
where it flips it from the original
values to 1 4 to 5 3 6 and back again so
we can move the data back and forth and
Transpo's that back and forth quite
easily with this so we touched a little
bit of bond the basics understanding of
numpy it's a really powerful tool we
need to move on and look at functions
functions are so important in Python
they're kind of programmers
bread-and-butter so let's do a function
just call this a fun and in our fun I
wanted to print simply learn so what I'm
doing is I'm creating a function it
allows me to call this piece of script
whenever I want
so instead of having the loop do this I
now have the function do this and
instead of maybe I have this function
where I went to print simply learn I'm
at five different places in my program
instead of retyping it I can just wrap
it all up in a wrapper function wrapper
and we can simply just call this the way
you call it as you just type in the name
fun because that's the name of our
function little confusing there for fun
simply learn is fun I like that kind of
combination and if we run this you'll
see just simply prints simply learn
because this function executes whatever
is in this indent and you can see right
here is our death let's it know it's a
definition the name of our function and
then a set of brackets right here now if
we want to do something I'm you know
it's exciting just be able to print
something if you want to add two numbers
let's go ahead and do a comma B we can
now put these numbers in these brackets
and this function now sees these numbers
in here let me go ahead and print this
just print a plus B and I'm gonna do
come down here and go add and we'll do
five for comma five we'll run that and
if we run that you see four plus five
equals nine
well we might not want to just run it we
might want to actually have a value come
out of it and so instead we'll do s for
summation equals a plus B and then I
want to return this value so now I can
come over here and I can do we'll just
call it in for a number equals add four
comma 5 and if we print in you'll see
this whole process now brings it all
together so now I have my function I'm
sending it a comma B it's gonna add a
comma B and it's going to return the
results for that and then I get that
under my end so I set this variable
equal to that and I print in and
something
want to point out is that this return s
is a tuple and we'll talk about that
again in just a minute
or let's why not we'll just go ahead and
do that now so we have our summation and
then we might have the difference what's
the difference between a minus B minus B
and I'm gonna leave this just as in so
you can see what that looks like but
we're gonna return s comma D the
different sum and difference and if I
print it out you'll see that it returns
nine that's our s and D is a minus one
and it's in a tuple form so as comedy
returns it's nice to pull we can also
instead of doing this I could do in one
comma in two and then we can print in
one comma in two and we did this earlier
where we are signing variables it's the
same thing but instead of assigning this
in one coming in to equaled it to
whatever they are nine comma minus one
we're having a return from our function
so it comes right out there and then we
can print the two different values and
then this is kind of an interesting
thing we can come up here and preset our
values going in instead of a I'm sending
it for cometh five and I say a equals 1
B equals 3 let's do the other way around
let's go 5 if I run this now remember
last time we sent it 4 or 5 and I got 9
minus 1 now I'm sending at 4 or 5 and I
still get the 9 minus 1 but if I take
this out and I don't send it any values
it'll automatically default to the a
equals 5 and B equals 3 and then we get
our 8 to 5 plus 3 is 8 5 minus 3 is 2 so
we've covered a lot so far as far as the
basic definition sending it information
returns it as a tuple one of the tricks
you can do is a star args they call them
args and corks and we're going to talk a
little bit about what the difference is
between args and corks they are
designated with the asterisks so this is
args no I don't have to call it R so I
could call it my args that is not
specific to the program let me just go
ahead and print I always like to do
lower case or the first letter and then
when I change names upper case and
that's just kind of a Python
standardization for naming your
different variables and if I print my
arse
and come back down here and I can do
let's just call this call this a k4 args
and quark so spell it out args args
underscores there we go
and so if I go in down here and I go hey
let's call my function paste that down
here and we'll come in here and I'm
gonna put in one two three four it might
be I don't know how many values I have
going in I just know that I have a bunch
of values that are gonna come in and I
know what order they're in and so you
can see right here it takes my args we
print out my args and I typed in one two
three four and that's what comes in and
we could do something like this we could
print args of one because maybe that's a
specific set up and it'll print two one
is the twos in the one place that's our
index and if we're doing like addition
we could do something like C equals my
args 0 - let's do addition plus my args
1 and you can guess on here if we return
call it a we can come down here and do a
equals args of Korg's
and then if I print our a and I run this
you can see it comes up with three
because one plus two equals three and it
might be that you only do stuff if 3 & 4
exist let's just do it this way well
this is fine so you can see right here
that we can now send it whatever args I
want and it will do those in a list so I
could send significantly more values in
here than it's up here and that's okay
and that's how your args work again the
asterisk so where does quarks come in
what does kW args mean well instead of
my args let's go star star let's go
Astro gastric or star star my kW args
and let's just go ahead and take a look
and see what these look like let's print
them out
grab this variable up here and again
it's the double asterisks just lets us
know that this is a core and down here
where I'm calling my definition I'm
gonna go ahead and change this up and
I'm gonna say a equals 10 and B equals
20 and then we have returned a let's
just take the return a out for right now
and just have a print it and if I run
this you'll see it comes up with a 10 B
20 we haven't talked about ditch
Canaries we didn't cover dictionaries
yet it's a special kind of set and the
way the dictionary works is you have
your index or key and it has a value and
the index or key is immutable you can't
change it you can delete it you can add
it but you can't change it and you can
change the in value and so you can see
right here we have an index of a and an
index of B and so I could also do print
my works and instead of doing 0 I can
now do a and we'll do addition we'll do
plus my course would be hit the wrong
button there okay
plus my quirks of B and if we run this
and of course you got to make sure this
is a string the a value here is
definitely a string coming in we can do
print my course of a plus Mike works a B
and you can see that we get 10 plus 20
equals 30 so this is just a really cool
way to send information to your function
and have it be able to like you might
have all kinds of stuff in here you need
to send once you send it you can do all
your different processes you can also do
if you remember from before I can do
something like this let's do this F a in
my corks and E in my corks then print
Mike works of a plus my course a B and
you can see right here if I change this
instead of to a I could change it to C
and run it and it'll say hey I've got a
value of C I've got a value B because I
not in there I'm not going to do this
addition so you start to get into some
logic gates that make sure you have the
data you're processing in there and what
you're working on and then one last cool
thing to remember is that our definition
is an object so like any other object
and we'll talk a little bit more about
objects here in a minute I can assign it
to a variable so I can do D equals my
args corks then I could do D of I'll do
a equals 1 comma B equals 2 and if I run
this I'll go and run that you'll see our
first run which we already had up here
where a C 10 B 20 and then you'll see I
ran it again this time it has a equals 1
B equals 2 and it sums them together as
3 so you can assign this value you can
assign this whole definition to a
variable
the final thing we want to touch upon
with our definition in our functions is
the recursive we've already discussed
the whole reason having a definition as
I can now call it from multiple times
from different parts of my program so
that if I know I need to add certain
numbers together I don't have to repay
Cisco din every time I need that I just
access my definition in a single line so
recursive means the program this
definition calls itself and just like
the while statement you run the risk of
running an indefinite loop and of course
if you're stuck in an indefinite loop
that will eventually crash your program
you're running so we might have I will
call this definition rec for recursive
and we want to take in and we want to do
something with it so we might say hey if
N equals one print in and return so when
we hit the value of one on end we know
this recursive function is done that's
what this is doing but if it doesn't
equal one we might want it to print in
and then we could do something like this
return recursive of n minus one so let's
take a look and see what's going on here
the first thing it does is it says hey
if N equals one we're done with this
Luke it is a loop it's looping in on
itself and what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and print in and then just
return and then we come down here we say
well if it's not equal to one we want to
print in and then we want to run this
loop again within minus one so we're
changing our logic gate here's our n n
keeps changing so in starts off at one
value and we keep subtracting and then
we can just do something like this I can
do let's do a recursive and we'll redo
with three and we'll run this and I get
three two one
why because each time it goes down here
and it subtracts one that goes back into
this then it says okay three minus one
is an equal to one no print it out once
we printed it out do n minus one and so
on and you can see right here we just do
a simple count down certainly there's
more complicated scripts you can write
but you can see how the simple recursive
value works we can use this to solve a
factorial problem let's call this
factorial deaf actor n will change this
down here so we call it and run it and
if you remember factorial is simply
value we want to return call this F F
equals 1 for I in range let's see would
it be in range of 1 comma in plus 1
remember it doesn't include the last one
so we have to add that extra plus 1 on
there for our range and we simply do F
equals F we can actually do this the
Python way F x equals I so f equals F
times I and it just keeps going through
and finds out what all the factorials
are and if we do this return F we can
print our factorial of 3 there we go and
we run this and we'll get a nice value 6
so 1 times 2 times 3 equals 6
we could also do this as a recursive
problem just like before we need some
kind of break that says hey we're done
so we'd say if N equals 1 let's just
return 1 if it doesn't equal 1 then what
we want to do is we want to return the
factorial of n minus 1
yeah the factorial of n minus 1 times n
that's what I want to do so we take the
value we have and we multiply it times a
factorial of n minus 1 so if our value
is 3 we're going to multiply that times
the factorial of 2 and we take 2 we
multiply that times the factorial of 1
well 1 is 1 so you're multiplying 1
times 2 and then back again to 3 and so
if we take out take out this part right
here now we have the same code in
factorial using recursion and it just
goes right down the list right there and
if we run this will get the same value 6
just like we expect it and I want to go
back a step let's just real quickly go
back to here there we go fry and range 1
F equals we did the x equals F or I so
we're going through here and this one
looks pretty good we've gone through and
it adds up the factorial but as a
recursion problem if you remember
quickly this one just goes to the end we
know the exact answer danger the
recursion one as we go back here and do
a quick undo is is calling itself and
you can see right here if N equals 1 and
it just keeps going minus 1 and minus 1
and if I run this we get our 6 well what
if the value in here is minus 3
well we keep subtracting we go minus
three minus four and so on you can
already see there's gonna be a problem
and if I run this it will crash the
program because it gets stuck in a
recursive loop and here you go and gives
me the recursive error makam maximum
recursive death exceeded in comparison
so we actually have a limit on there so
you got to be real careful with your
recursive functions but they're also
really useful in handing a lot of
different scripting and computations I
hate to wrap up on an error so I'll
switch it back to three and run it so
we'll have our nice value of six so we
want to talk about next
lambda lambda is a very useful tool and
especially when we get into what they
call mapping and reducing functions map
and reduce itself is a Hadoop term and
there's an actual scripting code called
Map Reduce but it's also a programming
way of thinking so this is a very
important concept or a number of
important concepts we're gonna cover
with the lambda which means function
lambda just is up they called the lambda
function and how and why it works and
how it's used we're gonna do is we're
gonna take our add function from before
we had add a be very simple function to
do we have s equals a plus B return if I
run this it'll add the 10 plus 20 on
there 30 just like you would expect it
from our previous definitions the lambda
function or its basis is it actually
does all of this in one line of code so
that's the first thing we're going to
start with is there a very basic lambda
function the l equals lambda
there's our keyword lambda meaning it's
a function a comma B and we get a plus B
and so when you see this our lambda
function I can print L and then we can
do 10 20 this does exactly what we just
did with the add function it takes the
10 and the 20 it comes across as a tuple
there's our tuple being sent in the
tuple is a B and then it simply returns
a plus B whatever is on the right hand
side so the lambda is a simple function
now we can get really complicated by
using a function for the function but
you can just put your simple function
here a plus B L equals lambda
be : a plus B and we get our nice print
L 4 lambda 1020 we can also do some kind
of filtering in here so we'll do let's
create ourselves a list here's a list of
letters and let's say I want to take
this list and I want to filter it out so
we'll give it a variable here for our
lambda let's use X X is very commonly
used in lambda and then we'll put over
here X N and let's say if you remember
from before when we did the vowels we
had our a EE IOU and if we run this and
I go ahead and print L pop that back in
there and run forgot we're doing a
filter function I forgot the whole of it
we're going to do a list and we're gonna
do this list of a filter so we need two
brackets for the list I'll have my
filter and then I'll need brackets for
the filter what's going into the filter
and the filter comes in here we're gonna
put the lambda in there so let's break
this down I'm creating a list from that
list I'm filtering out and I'm going to
use the lambda function and the lambda
function says hey for each entity in
this list I want to know if X is in a e
i o u and if it is in a e i o u then at
that point i want to go ahead and add it
to my list and so here we're adding it
on to the LST over filtering the LST and
we're returning the value to go into
this list what you can do is you could
imagine that instead of this being a
list of these it might be a row in your
database you're processing so you have a
lot of data coming in and you can see
right here it filters it out it gets rid
of the B and the F and we end up with
our æøå
it filters it out so imagine that you're
sitting in a row in your database so for
each row we want to know what the the
lambda is and it processes each
character in this data this could easily
be an array or columns you know from
your row we might have column a name
first name last name address and you
want to know which one of these is part
of something else so we've covered a
filter what I want to cover next is
mapping and a lot of times when I work
with filters and maps and I'm working
with data the terminology map when
you're thinking map is everything you
can do to one line or one row in your
database you don't need all the other
rows to
got it so mapping is another tool and
the actual use of map with lambda will
do a result equals equals map lambda and
then we're gonna take each character in
there and we're gonna just go orden
we're gonna convert it to its ASCII code
and we're gonna add one to it so we're
just gonna adjust it to each one and so
forgotten took out my actual list of
course PyCharm already remembers it
unless I restart the pycharm environment
so it's still work if I ran it so we
have our list a BEF o a then we're gonna
get a result let's go ahead and print
the result and run it and you can see
right here result and we'll convert it
into a list so when we print the result
we get be CFG PB
I'm guessing you know a the next one up
would be B be the next one up would be
Cee the next one up would be F and so on
and again when we're talking about maps
the mapping part of a program it's
whatever you can do on one line of data
and I bring that up and I keep saying
that over and over and over again
because when you touch upon data
processing and especially big data this
is how we're able to cover tera and
terabytes of data as we process one row
at a time and that's the mapping they
call that that is literally the mapping
we are mapping something if I look at
this raw data I don't need to know
anything else about the database other
than this row of data and that's I'm
going to map it if you're gonna map
something you need to go ahead and
reduce it because if you have a ton of
different rows in a database or whatever
you're working with in this case we're
just working with characters and a list
you want to reduce it to something
everybody can read something you can
process at a glance we do need to go
ahead and import reduce so we'll do that
from the function tools import reduce
that makes it much more legible instead
of doing fun tools dot reduce and then
we'll do our results equals reduce
lambda X of Y X plus low I of our list
and all we're saying here is for each
element that we look at we're going to
write this up and then we're just going
to keep adding it on to our list and if
we print out the result run it you'll
see we end up with a B e fo a and that's
from the original list
remember this lambda result is not
tear this is the list is being fit into
your fact let's go ahead and remove the
map and keep the map up there and reduce
so we mapped it and then we take so
we're processing each individual
character in their map we're processing
each individual character in this list
changing it tacking it on to the lists
or returns the differences and then
we're going to bring them all together
so we're doing a reduction reducing it
into one string down here so we've
covered a lot we've had our functions we
looked at our lambda the next thing we
want to look at is modules and we've
already been looking at that without
even knowing it and we'll start with I'm
gonna call this I renamed this one mod
1py this is stuff we already did earlier
so we had our prime of a or even number
of a def prime of a equals 4 I and range
to come a if the remainder of a divided
by I equals 0 print numbers not prime
return number is prime and then we also
did even print numbers even print
numbers odd so this is something we did
earlier we created these definitions to
let us know whether it's even or odd
I've changed the name to mod 1 dot py
and this is gonna be saved in the same
folder as our scratch so this script
that I'm gonna write in here is in the
same folder you can also put it in your
library so if you have your environment
and you have all your library folders
which has all the other default Python
including the modules we import it this
will access either one and what we can
simply do on this is we can now import
our mod 1 and so we can do from mod 1
import everything so that's going to
import our two definitions it's going to
import prime and it's going to import
even and so anything we do in here can
now access that so we can now do N
equals integer let's do an enter input
enter number so we're gonna have it
input a number it's going to force it to
be an integer so now we have our in and
we'll simply do print and let's take a
look over here we had from our module we
had print prime of a or even of a those
are our two options on there that's what
we brought in so I can do print prime
and we're gonna send in back there and I
can also do print or actually there's no
pricks
no return statement so it's just prime
of N and even of those are the two
things we imported and if we run that
it's gonna ask me to enter a number
we'll enter in 3 or 23 in this case and
you'll say number is prime number is odd
so 23 is a prime number and it's also an
odd numbers even or odd this can be very
complicated because you could also do
you add a select in here run this if I
have a selection of a or B or whatever
but at this point you're now writing
modules for your script and you can see
how you can easily organize a very
lengthy program by having your different
modules built outside of what you're
working on so you're not you don't have
this huge length of like hundreds of
lines of code to read through you only
have a little piece you're working on
and you can share these modules that way
if you're working as a group just like
we imported math very or dumpy-dumpy as
in P we can now share these modules with
other people who can then utilize them
for their projects let's go ahead and
close out of this and clear up my area
I'm working with and we're gonna jump
into the next big topic that is not
meaning that I just knocked my coffee
over and spilled it all over my desk but
object-oriented programming and we're
gonna start with the theory there's a
lot of theory behind oops it's been
around for since the 90s very central to
just about any programming language out
there and earlier when I pointed out
that your functions we do the DEF
statement def whatever your function
name is that those are objects we can
actually set them to variables and so
object-oriented programming is what this
is all centered on we have an object
everything in Python is an object if you
look at it programming paradigm that
focuses on objects every instance in
Python is an object so like I just said
everything you do in Python you have an
object you're looking at an object has
attributes so we have data that
describing the object and it has
behavior methods on the attributes these
are your definitions your functions and
your tributes are your your list your
arrays your numpy array your variables
all those are attributes and so for
example if we have a BMW I don't drive a
BMW myself actually of a beautiful
pickup truck given where I live I would
prefer my trip pickup truck to the BMW
but if I live someplace else I would
definitely like a nice BMW to drive
around so for an example you have your
manufacturer maximum speed those are all
attributes of your BMW and for behavior
you might have you might display the
speed because the speeds always changing
so there you go those are all behavior
as you accelerate the amount of gas
going into the engine changes as you
push on the brake you're pushing on the
brake is a behavior and it's changing
the speed of the car so we define a
class class is a collection of similar
objects so for example a car we have BMW
we have Ford we have a knotty
the inheritance mechanism for a new
class to use the features of another
class so we have a number of different
things inheritance we might have our
class which is vehicles and then under
vehicles we might have cars and cars
inherits all the different stuff from
vehicles so we have inheritance so you
can create a class from another class
the feats are preventing data from
direct access is called encapsulation so
when we have our object programming we
have integers we looked at integers you
can't actually access integer you assign
a variable that has all the different
features and functions of an integer but
you don't access the actual integer
object you can't but generally you don't
you have it encapsulated so that it is
never altered and polymorphism is a
feature of using the same function in
multiple ways so you can think of this
in in our example of vehicles and cars
we might also have vehicles and bicycles
well bicycles accelerate very different
than a car does a car you step on the
gas a bicycle you step on the pedal both
of them have a similar acceleration you
want to apply more that function so that
it works the same for both of those but
it does something very different so
let's go ahead and create our class
we'll call it car we have our semicolon
here which says that whatever comes
after this is indented as part of the
class car now there's some things we're
leaving out here you'll almost always
see brackets and variables in there look
at that in just a moment let's just
start with the class car and we might
have car type must give
a tribute this particular tribute is a
car type and we'll set it equal to
manual and this is a global variable
we've set up on here let's use
throughout the setup throughout the
class car and then we want to create a
death and this is a very special
definition remember that's a function
for death and we call it omit the stands
for initialize and we put a double
underscore before it and a double score
underscore after it what that means is
when I create this class an instance of
the class not the class itself but I
create this instance of this class I
create a variable equal to car this
initializes it and self means that it's
referring to itself whenever you see
self in the class you're referring to
that instance and we'll look at that a
little bit more closer in just a minute
so hopefully if you're confused we'll be
able to help you with that
well go ahead and get past a couple
variables speed so when we initiate
class we're gonna pass a year and speed
and then self is just part of the what's
passed into the definition and we'll go
ahead and do self year equals year and
self speed equals speed so up here we
have a global variable and down here we
have an instance feature I used variable
and feature kind of interchangeably but
certainly features probably the more
appropriate word but they are variables
also either way they're the same thing
and then let's go ahead and create a
what's called a static method and you
set it that by doing the at symbol here
and we'll call it static method this is
a command let's just know that this is
not specific to an object or the classes
variable so this is independent of our
specific initiation and with this we're
gonna do welcome and we'll just have it
do a print down here I'll go print
welcome to the car showroom kind of fun
there so here's our so I forgot to put
the DEF in front of welcome this is
tabbed in so when we do this when I have
our instance this never changes it's a
static method it's always going to do
the same thing it doesn't matter where
it's coming from it doesn't need to
access any other information
in any other features in the class car
or whatever initiated variable I have
and then we'll do something a little
more traditional on Def get speed
automatically does the self and in this
case we're just gonna do print maximum
speed is self dot speed remember we
initiated it so here's our self dot
speed self means it's the instance we're
creating is not the actual class but the
instance and we're gonna print that out
and so let's take a look at that and
just see how this all comes together I
did forget one piece of the two of the
puzzle just like we have a static method
I can do this up here we also have
what's called class specific so when you
have a class specific method you denote
that with class method now remember the
static method doesn't care anything
about what's in the class it doesn't
care about the initiation it has all the
information it needs with the class
method we need to go ahead and use have
information this class specific and we
did that up here when I did class and I
did car type equals manual so that's the
feature that we can access underneath
this title will create a definition here
and we'll call this type we'll just do
CLS because it's a class method that's
what the CLS stands for and then we're
gonna do print we're in my showroom and
we say these cars are CLS car type so
the CLS just refers to the class class
our variables without the self in front
so when I have a class or a feature
underneath class any instance I create
is going to have car type equals manual
where when I initiate it and I have self
any feature like self dot year self dot
speed is going to be just that instance
has that feature with revalue we put
into it and then we have a static method
which only accesses the static method it
doesn't have any other information
coming into it from either the class or
external and then you can see here we
have type class denoted by CLS and we
can print the class type and then we
have the self
there's our self our most basic
definition get speed and the way this
works is we have our be of the store
here's our BMW so our BMW equals make
sure there's no spaces in front of it
it's going to equal car and we have our
car class back up here I did it all
lowercase a lot of times car the classes
you want to start with a capital letter
you don't have to but that just is like
a kind of a programmer standard on there
so you can number that it is a class
versus a variable which we start with
lowercase and if you go up here to
initial we have self which it
automatically sends because this is part
of the car and then we have your and
speed and so we want to go ahead and
send those in there we move 2018 and
we'll say as a maximum speed of 155 I
don't usually living where I do I don't
go over 75 or 80 at the tops due to the
particular laws we have and we'll do a
forward in this particular forward on
their showroom but a 2016 and maybe your
Ford has a maximum speed of 140 so now
we've created two instances and if I do
BMW to get speed you'll see here that it
doesn't the self which I put in here
isn't need it because it already pulls
the self in that is the the instance
it's saying the BMW which I called it is
pulling in BMW on here and all the
features with self are pulled into it
also so if I run this you'll see down
here that it pulls up the speed is this
maximum speed is 155 for our BMW and
let's say we want to know about the Ford
maybe we'll do Ford get speed and we run
this and the maximum speed for the Ford
is a hundred and forty and of course
we're looking at the little ticker tape
of the car and along comes a guy who
says hey do you want to buy a car and
we'll do the car welcome and if we run
that it says messed up on this because
it's a capital C there we go and we do
the car welcome it says welcome to the
car showroom maximum speed is 140 on the
car you're looking at our salesman's
come up and approach this and then
finally we might be looking around the
showroom and saying hey what kind of
showroom is this what are you guys
showing to me we can do car type we see
that it comes up these cares
typo there these cars are and then it
looks at the car type it says manual so
you're in the manual car showroom now
this is all great you have your class
car let me go ahead and just get rid of
this stuff take it back a notch clean it
up
check out people are B&W and for down
there and so with our class car
we now have under there and an it will
keep the Annette where we put in the
year and the speed and we set that I've
taken out my static method but I do want
to add and let's go back and put the get
speed back in itself get speed and we'll
just print like we had before maximum
speed and because we put it in as a for
the instance will do self dot speed
that's how we reference it there so
right now we have our basic class car
and that looks pretty good but what if
we're talking about remember we had like
these models are all standard these
models are all whatever what if I want
to have a class sedan so we're looking
at just sedans but I wanted to have all
the features of the car I don't want to
have to do a economy sedan four-wheel
drive I don't want to redo all the work
I do in car because the get speeds going
to be the same the year and everything
else is going to be the same what I can
do is we can do an inheritance and that
means when I do a class sedan of car
this inherits everything from car so
everything I have above in car is
inherited so any instance I creative
sedan uses all the values in car and we
can do we can change some things on here
but let me just show you how this works
to begin with instead of doing I can do
this part right here let me just do the
MW get speed so I still have my car
class so if I run this you will see
indent error because I forgot I created
this here's go pass is just a fancy way
of putting a placeholder here or saying
the code is here but don't do anything
so I process maximum speed is 155 and
what happens instead of a car we do a
sedan and we run this I still get
maximum speed is 155 well sedan doesn't
have that in there but sedan inherited
everything from car so when we look at
this I have maximum speed equals self
speed and I admit the initialization is
the same self dot year self dot speed on
there now we can also do something like
this with sedan I can take true copy all
this over generally don't just do a pass
here the very least you need your knit
file in this
so here's my initialization and so with
sedan we're going to do something like
this I'm gonna go super nit year comma
speed and what I'm telling it is it
comes in and says okay I'm initializing
a sedan this is my initialization code
but we're gonna go to the class that
this inherited from which is our car and
we're gonna do the init there this
basically comes up here and says okay
this is our knit this is how we're gonna
initialize this but in addition to that
what I want to do is I also want to do
something like this print this is a
sedan and so now when I run this our BMW
initializes as a sedan it does the super
so it uses all of the anit code
underneath our class car and then in
addition to that is whatever I wanted to
do in this case I want to just print
this is a sedan so you can see it prints
this is a sedan and then when I run get
speed it still utilizes that from the
original class so now I also have the
speed and the initialization all under
my original class car
I'm not recreating it retyping it
copying it down there and just like we
have deafs appear under class we might
have certain definitions which are very
specific to the sedan so maybe we have
open trunk so we'll put that in there
there's our definition for open trunk
and all it does is print open trunk and
so I can do B FW dot open trunk and if I
run this my BMW now can open the trucks
now it has additional functionality that
cars doesn't we can see this if I do
four dot open trunk and if you guess
that'd give us a error you're correct
car doesn't have an open trunk I'm sorry
it's an error this for maybe it's a Ford
truck doesn't have a trunk so it can't
open it so this is only if it's a sedan
does it have open trunk underneath of it
and this just adding meal that new
definitions is our polymorphism we can
polymorph our class to do things
original class couldn't do and we can go
ahead we could take this let's just
change this up a little bit here
initialize this with name and then self
dot name and instead of having setting
the speeds here just just say that this
particular individual car maximum speed
of 150 forget
bead and we'll do the same thing down
here we'll have our instead of a sedan
let's do this let's just take this
completely out of here well take our
Sudan and the sedan will have a speed of
a hundred and fifty but instead of us
yes sedan that works we'll just do sedan
and then maybe we'll also have another
one that is an SUV and so our SUV class
they all have a maximum speed of 120
this SUV and so now that we have these
two classes they're both inheriting from
cars so when we send something to them
we're gonna send named self-named and
then we have deaf can get speed which is
gonna return 150 class SUV maximum speed
is 120
so we're storing the name underneath the
each instance of it and then we're also
going to get a different speed each time
let's do a list we'll do a car list
here's our list of cars
there's our brackets for our list and
then I'm going to do something kind of
fun here here's a sedan
now the sedan is the class so that's an
object so I can make a list of that
object and in that particular object
we're gonna give it a name and the name
of this one is going to be a Camry very
common car out there and then I'm gonna
create a second object it's going to be
an SUV class remember we'd also did
variables as definitions certainly you
can put anything that's an object into a
variable so these are lists of classes
on here with their calls and the SUV
we're gonna do I guess Scorpio to
familiar with the Scorpio car but in
case it's one of the common SUVs in
certain areas so now I have a list of
two classes and these classes are both
initialized the first one with Camry and
with Scorpio and from before we can do
for car and car lists so we're gonna do
each car and then we're just gonna do
something simple like print in this case
car dot name and kind of a fun one we'll
add the plus sign in the brackets the
colon and just a second to put this
together comma end equals double
brackets this is basically we're telling
it don't print a new line I want to
print the car followed by car accelerate
remember we had actually we did to get
speed
we'll do we'll stick with good speed
control copy get speed put it in our
double brackets I'm just gonna add a
space up here and here
oops actually goes at the beginning so
if I run this it should go all the way
through this list here's our for loop
remember this that we talked about
iterating through a list of objects
there's our car list and as we go
through we see Scorpio we have our Camry
Camry is maximum speed 150 Scorpio
maximum speed 120 so we put together a
nice set of pulling off ISM of classes
we polymorphed our car class into a
sedan and into an SUV so these have
these print out a very different thing I
have a very different get speed
functionality but they both inherit the
initial death from car so we've covered
a lot today we've covered a lot across
the spectrum on some basic Python from
variables we talked about this sets
tuples we talked about arrays and numpy
arrays we talked about truth functions
and operators math functions input we
talked about true the if-else and our
true/false logic or while loop or for
loop break continue we talked about
functions with our args follow it
started by an asterisks or a double
asterisk for KWR X we talked about
recursion and our definitions and
functions recursion in our definitions
and functions we discussed lambda just a
little bit on map and reduce then we
looked at modules how you can create
your own modules in the framework and we
also covered object-oriented programming
concepts and classes initialization
along with inheritance encapsulation and
polymorphism so we covered a lot today I
want to thank you for joining me
hopefully we'll have a part two of this
which you can follow up along with many
of our other great tutorials that we put
out for more information visit
www.mptv.org/outdoorwisconsin
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here